you know guys this is the first MCU press
screening I've ever been to where they
actually gave the audience a free alcoholic
beverage and you know what that usually
means for anyone who's been to plenty of
press screenings when they're throwing a
free alcohol you you know how the studio
really feels about what they got on their
hands what is going on there citizens of the
reject ation Greg and John here today we just
watched the marbles Burbank is quite serious about
any kind of recording so we're going to have to
keep this quick and I'm glad we do because I'm
going to be very very direct with you guys leave
a like on this video if you dare to John quickly
give them the plot if there is one that's an easy
task hey look there's this uh cre Warrior who's
real mad about the events of Captain Marvel so
she's searching out uh you know various means
of extracting Revenge let's just put it that
way meanwhile Miss Marvel Kamala Khan Carol daners
Captain Marvel and Monica Rambo they all discover
uh that their powers are interlined somehow all
those circumstances intertwin to where they got to
figure out what this weird power switching thing
is and how to stop the villain that's kind of what
it's about okay all right I'm just going to give
you guys uh some quick thoughts here Aman volani
is easily the best part of this whole movie to me
I thought that might be the case before watching
this film sure enough she is she steals every
scene she's in I like the appearance from her
family that is laced throughout this entire film
as well I thought they were great John did you
like Aman volani very much so definitely she's
great right yep she is terrific Brie Larsson boy
have they made her relatable she is Rel cracking
wise she's having some fun she's lightened up a
bit I really like Brie Larson individually quite
a bit her personality I thought she was much more
appealing this time around I quite enjoyed
all three of them yes at least individually
and often times together and and Tiana Paris
is another terrific actor you know she's doing
good stuff with what they're giving her yes yes
I would say that too and the movie occasionally
has some cool visuals occasionally there's
some cool action scenes I don't know about
a whole scene but there'll be moments within
the action like there's this whole thing where
whenever they use their powers or switching spots
with each other and sometimes there's some really
cool choreography that happens there that is
the word that came to mind watching it I was
like there some cool inventive choreography here
and I thought generally when it gave way to an
action scene which are often the scenes the movie
lets breathe the most you know there's some pretty
Punchy stuff in there the music is occasionally
good it's much brighter in tone than I'm used to
from an MCU there were times where I'm like oh
we're going lighter we're going more triumphant
we're going something that reminds me more of
I don't know why Danny Alman but kind of listen
guys when this movie was done KY was sitting next
to me and everyone knows KY is the guy who's the
most forgiving of the MCU he looked at me and
I don't want to just give away his review I'm
going to say it right now though because I could
not agree more he said this is not what Marvel
needs right now fair I really tried to like this
movie the first I'd say 20 to 30 minutes of it I
was like all right it's edited a little weird
tastes a little funny it looks like a TV show
but I'm having fun it's messy but I'm having fun
but then eventually for me seems like you're a
lot nicer about it than me and I'm totally okay
I don't want to run anyone's parade we went to a
screening where there's a mixed bag there there's
a lot of people who really liked it and good for
you if you really like it for me I think this is
one of the worst MCU movies that they have ever
done and I was really trying because I think these
three actresses while great they deserved a much
better movie than this and sure is there an end
credit scene and a post credit scene that is so
important to the future of the MCU abs absolutely
and I would advise not letting the importance of
what it is setting up disuade you into thinking
that what you just watched is a great film because
it's not in fact there are things about the post
credit scene that actively OBS I I buried my head
and I can't I I think I said out loud like I can't
believe they just there's one choice they make
about it where I could not believe that they did
it in the post-credit scene specifically the movie
itself I thought was terribly edited throughout
terribly pasted I felt nothing I thought the
movie was in a rush to finish they reaches a rush
to do anything it sets its mind to it goes in and
out of scenes that are supposed to have emotion
John was on my right cor on left turn like what
is happening right now like why are they just
like speeding through it I think it is the worst
comic book movie I have seen all year I don't like
the first Captain Marvel movie that one at least
feels like an actual movie this felt like they
took an entire season's worth of a Disney Plus
show crammed it into 2 and 1/2 hours and then
said 2 and 1/2 hours is too long we got to trim
it down to an hour and 40 minutes I do not think
this is a good movie and I'm not apologizing for
it it's not a good movie great actors in it some
good action Samuel Jackson looks bored as [__]
does not feel like the performance carrying over
from Secret Invasion whatsoever I mean I can Abide
a lighter toned Fury and even lack of continuity
from characterization I know comic books will do
that but but yeah it's a bit disconcerting the
way they handled Nick Fury throughout a lot of
the comedy is done through this like lacad isical
we don't really care kind of attitude that casual
like well that's kind of weird sort of Comedy
yeah Marvel released this trailer the final one
for the Marvels it is not that tone I guarantee
you there are some scenes in this movie that are
some of the cheesiest cringiest scenes you will
ever see in any of the MCU and I feel so bad for
what some of these actors are going to be going
through because of the movie they deliver when it
is not their fault they're great and they're
giving it their all and I really [__] mean
that it's weird and messy at times it gets to a
point where like I think it's maybe intentional
I can see someone surrendering to the mess and
just going whatever I'm having fun with it it's
a fantasy chaos I feel like I got to say something
nice there's some cat stuff in on I'm like I'm a
cat lover look I've chocked up a lot of movies
of my experience of going like yeah it's messy
and whatever but I had fun this is one of those
experiences where the mess just overrode the fun
for me John please say nice things because you're
on a much higher note than I am about it all right
yes I mean I I was having some kind of a blast
throughout a lot of this movie it certainly is
all over the place it is a very much and then
kind of a plot where just random things will
pop up and they don't really give much time to
pay attention to them however the color and the
levity of everything and the sort of bounciness
had me enjoying myself for a good amount of it
there is a Crossroads I think you will come to
as a viewer depending on how much that enjoyment
is bolstering your experience where it may kind
of plateau and sort of drop off for you or it'll
start to make you mad I am in the camp where
I was always kind of pleasantly enjoying it
sometimes genuinely sometimes sort of in spite
of the strange cacophony this movie becomes I
don't begrudge a Marvel movie feeling a bit like
a cartoon a bit disconnected in terms of like the
immediacy of the continuity stuff like that is
cool when it happens but I'm not hanging on that
so a lot of this I was like cool as long as this
is a fun colorful sort of bonding experience with
just enough Stakes I'm happy the trouble for me
is that you don't really get much chance to lch
on to any of the stakes no no no for sure like I
thought um I I'm blanking on the actress's name
zawe something or other the villain yes oh my
God what a terrible villain whatever her name
is terrible villain she's another one of those
villains that isy to have a very capable actor do
all of the work to make this any kind of character
looking badass very underwritten the main three I
don't think that this movie is really bolstering
their Journey as characters again I'm not asking
these movies to be the deepest I'm not asking for
some kind of impactful meaningful allegory however
there are character threads that are meaningful
that would help this movie be more enjoyable us
enjoy and love these characters that much more
based on something other than pre-existing
knowledge that they leave on the table there are
opportunities for the history between Carol and
and and uh Monica to be rectified that are touched
upon but not really unpacked and those things are
the saddest parts of the movie to me because
there are lots of opportunities for some actual
impactful character work they do not take I felt
kind of bad when the credit started to roll cuz I
was like I don't think this is really any of the
creative fault I doubt this is what any of those
three writers wanted this movie to look like I
doubt this is exactly the calling card Nia wanted
out of this experience everybody for the most part
shows up but it is like a weird episode of do it's
like one of those Doctor Who episodes that is like
a loud mess and sometimes those are fun and in
this case I had fun with that but sometimes those
are grading and not fun and I feel like it's just
as valid to fall on that other side basically
at a certain point it does start to plateau
and then you start to notice the defici genes of
the actual plotting film making characterization
Etc that keep this from succeeding despite the
aspects that are maybe a bit messy I mean I don't
begrudge anyone who ends up actually liking this
movie I did not have high expectations for this
movie somehow it came in exceedingly under what
I expected out of this movie and I think that the
directing on this is not really shown well like
you hear these reports coming out like this does
not feel like Nea to cost's Direction I can't even
get my thought to death it feels Studio noted to
death it's the one of the most comedi made Marvel
movies I've seen in a very very long time it feels
like somebody panicked and they're like this has
to make up for so much and also be the next huge
installment and set up all the important [__]
to come and I think it buckles under the weight
of not just choosing one and being that I think
these characters and these actors they deserved
a much better film for sure The Sisterhood
deserves better they really did because they're
not the problem with this movie at all they're not
they're the only thing that kind of saves the film
at times with the occasional cool visual moment
but most of the time I'm like I don't even care
what's happening on screen it feels like such
an an impassive experience honestly that's my
thoughts on it I'm kind of baffled by how much
I didn't like it I'm like a 2.5 to three out of
10 on this film I'm more like a six you know
like I had enough fun I have fun uh but yeah
there's a lot of ways this could have been great
and really enjoyable and heart swelling all right
let me edit this video so I can get bunch of
crap from everyone who already sold their minds
on whether they liked it that's it thanks for
being here see you see you soon cnx [Music] Marvel